thousands take to the streets around the
country to protest rakonin lockdowns the
Liberals and the squishes are furious
but President Trump is cheering them on
and believe it or not the anti lockdown
protesters are getting some
encouragement from one of the world's
leading public health experts then
congressman Dan Crenshaw destroys Bill
Maher's anti-trump talking points
Harvard tries to ban homeschooling and
brian Stelter cries all that more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
nul show
[Music]
brian Stelter cries is not exactly a man
by its Dog story but we will get to it
not because it's a shocking event but
because it tells us something about our
mainstream culture and certainly about
the mainstream media first we got to
cover these rallies I believe you know
how much I hate to say I told you so on
this show I never do it well I try not
to do it but I told you so I predicted a
few weeks ago and we were asked how long
is this shutdown going to go on for
people said it's gonna go on for six
months it's gonna go on for ten months
it's gonna go on for 18 months I said
it's not it can't go on for 18 months
because people will take to the streets
and that is already happening I thought
it would happen sometime after three
weeks four weeks in reality it wouldn't
what are we at now like five weeks are
pretty close people are taking to the
streets around the country to protest
the lockdowns and part of the reason
they're protesting them is you'll
remember everybody went along with the
lockdowns
when we were told we have to millions of
people are gonna die stay in your home
save lives everybody went along with it
there was no problem and then the number
has started to come at a real numbers
started to come out and all of a sudden
it wasn't 2 million people are gonna die
it wasn't four million people are gonna
die it was half a million people then it
was a hundred thousand people then it
was sixty thousand people now we just
don't know first we were told very few
people had it and then we're told
actually many many more people had it
we've got some news on that today from
from various scientists so then all of a
sudden we said hold on this is not
nearly as bad as people were saying it
was and instead of getting a little
looser with the lockdowns instead of the
politicians reacting to the new
scientific information and lightening up
a little bit instead they doubled down
and that's why people are protesting
it's happening in Arizona Colorado
Montana Washington State and another
many states as well people are sick and
tired of being told that they can't work
they can't make any money they can't do
any of the things that they want to do
they can't exercise their political
rights they can't even go outside in
most cases and President Trump for his
part is totally side
with the protestors here is a reporter
in the White House briefing room trying
to egg Trump on trying to get Trump to
turn against these protesters Trump
having none of it interviews are great
people look they want to get they call
cabin fever you've heard the term
they've got cabin fever they want to get
back they want their life back their
life was taken away from them and you
know they learned a lot during this
period they learn to do things
differently than they have in the past
and you know they'll do it hopefully
until the virus has passed and when the
virus passes I hope we're going to be
sitting next to each other in baseball
games football games basketball games
ice hockey games I hope we're going to
be sitting next to each other I hope you
have golf to the Masters is gonna have a
hundred thousand people not 25 people
watching at the course I think these
people are I've never seen so many
American flags I mean I'm seeing the
same thing that you sing I don't see it
any differently I totally would say no
wait but I've seen I didn't see that I
see you all of course I'm sure the news
plays that up I've seen American flags
all over the place I have never seen so
many American flags and a rally as I
haven't the Israelis these people love
our country they want to get back to
work that's the right tone that's the
right attitude between Trump and the
media on this question Trump is the
reasonable one the media is the
hysterical one because of course there
are Nazis right you heard that reporter
at the end Trump says there they're
waving American flags they just want
their lives back they want their rights
back they want their economy back and
the reporter said they're Nazis where's
the evidence that they're Nazis I don't
there's no ad that's what they say
anybody slightly to the right of Hillary
Clinton they call a Nazi okay
Trump is the reasonable one here media
are the unreasonable ones and on this
question of the reopening and the
protests guess what the protesters are
the reasonable ones and the vaunted
public health experts that say we need
to remain imprisoned in our own homes
for two years they are the unreasonable
ones it's a what the left has tried to
do this whole time is say that there are
only two options either completely grind
the global economy to a halt
imprison everybody inside of their own
homes do not go anywhere lose all of
your political rights or go outside and
do exactly what you want and everyone
will die that's what we were told those
are the two options those are not the
two options
minoes things are unreasonable right the
middle ground is much more reasonable
here middle ground perhaps being now
that we've seen that the virus is not as
virulent as we previously thought maybe
people who are basically healthy can go
back to work people who were frail and
who are old maybe should stay at home
still or should take responsible
measures
maybe we should all wash our hands maybe
we shouldn't shake shake hands this is
all the time just yet okay obviously
there is this reasonable middle ground
the media doesn't want any of it we have
a lot more credibility on this the
skeptical people because we all took it
seriously in the beginning and then the
doomsday models did not come to pass
I'll give you an example of this you
know each day the models are being
readjusted down just look at what
happened in Florida Florida model so
this was a Friday the main model that we
are using to look at coronavirus spread
and death the Institute for Health
metrics and evaluation changed its model
from Florida significantly it said that
the state will have 1363 deaths from
kovat 19 by August 4th that number is
down from the original productive
projects in which was 47 48 oh it's not
even the original production that's just
the projection they had earlier in the
week so earlier in the week they say
almost 5,000 deaths by August now we're
told that's going to be about 1,300
deaths by August this is good news right
this is a reason to celebrate but it's
also a reason to take a look at some of
our policies and say this is an
overreaction we don't need to give up
all of our rights we don't need to give
up our economy necessarily and yet some
people don't like the liberation talk
and we've got to get into that because
there's there's a real debate going on
over who's being responsible who's being
irresponsible and we've got to hear in
from Joe Biden on this issue but first
I've got to thank our friends over at
LifeLock you know there are some people
who were prepared for just about
everything all right and sometimes I'm
not prepared for everything that's where
LifeLock comes in breaches seem like
they're happening more and more these
days with your breached information like
your name your social security number
and more criminals can commit identity
theft that's why life lock sees more
threats like someone taking out a payday
loan in your name for instance it alerts
you to possible suspicious activity and
if you end up having an identity theft
issue you'll have a dedicated identity
restoration specialist just a phone call
away no one can prevent all identity
theft er monitor all transactions of all
businesses but with breaches on the rise
doesn't it make sense to be prepared of
course it does and I really trust these
guys if you're not protecting your
identity you can't complain if and when
your identity gets stolen join LifeLock
today save up to 25% of your first year
go to LifeLock comm slash knowles canna
wles that is LifeLock dot-com / Knowles
Cana wles
to save 25% so some conservatives
are a little upset with President Trump
and with the protestors Trump tweeted
out over the weekend he said liberate
Michigan liberate the state liberate
America raise encouraging the protesters
some people don't like that liberation
talk and they say that it's
irresponsible
really what is irresponsible here is a
letting politicians get away with
massive power grabs which is what they
are doing ok I want this to be crystal
clear when this was briefly just a
medical scientific biological issue we
were all on board to protect people and
save lives then the left politicized
this thing and they started passing
absurd policies that had nothing to do
with the coronavirus they tried to get
the green New Deal into the coronavirus
funding package don't forget that they
tried to hold small business funding
hostage so that they could reduce fuel
emissions in commercial airliners
they took the opportunity to like
criminals out of jail even while they
were arresting law-abiding citizens
because they weren't paying enough heed
to the public health experts okay these
were huge paragraphs
what is irresponsible is letting the
politicians get away with it
we need to liberate America simple as
that does not mean that we need to
reopen Manhattan tomorrow okay doesn't
mean we need to reopen the center of
Boston tomorrow where we see some
hotspots but we don't need to lock down
South Dakota okay we don't need to lock
down Montana we need to start taking a
much more scientific view of this entire
thing and looking where the hotspots
aren't looking where the hotspots or not
we will do that just a second this
reaction has gone very very far there is
no evidence whatsoever that continued
nationwide lockdowns are helping
anything all right
and the power grabs are too much for
more on that we turn now to Democratic
presidential candidate Joe Biden we got
it it's just but you gotta I mean the we
got agree sure look my my message to
everybody I talked to yep that's very
insightful stuff Thank You mr. Biden in
New York City we are seeing the flaws of
this strategy already okay I guess we've
seen them for a while if you want to see
flawed political strategy look to New
York City the bolshevik mayor there bill
de blasio is now using this crisis as an
opportunity to try to turn citizens into
government
snitches his new policy is if you see
anybody not listening to the vaunted
public health experts and more
importantly anybody not listening to me
mayor de Blasio you should rat you
should take photos of them you should
upload those photos and you should rat
them out to the government now look
thank you everyone who's done it the
right way but we still know there's some
people need to get the message and that
means sometimes making sure the
enforcement is there to educate people
and make clear we got to have social
distancing so now it is easier than ever
when you see a crowd when you see a line
that's not distance when you see a
supermarket that's too crowded anything
you can report it right away so we can
get help there to fix the problem and
now it's as simple as taking a photo all
you got to do is take the photo and put
the location with it and bang send a
photo like this and we will make sure
that enforcement comes right away text
the photo the three one one six nine two
and action will ensue enforcement will
come to get the help we need or you can
use the three one one app send that
photo there and you'll make sure
immediately there's follow-up three one
one six nine two and enforcement will
ensue sure would be a shame if people
texted their opinion of this policy and
photos to that number wouldn't it sure
would be a dirty rotten shame you know
when I was a kid I was told that
snitches get stitches now we're being
told that tattletaling is going to be
the full-time policy of the city of New
York it reminds me a very good advice
that mr. Brady gave his daughter in a
very Brady movie by tattling on someone
you're really just telling them I'm a
tattletale now is that the tale you want
to tell does that the tale you want to
tell I don't think so and it's so
profoundly hypocritical de Blasio is is
the most hilarious person to be pushing
this policy because in the early days of
the pandemic when President Trump was
taking it seriously and liberals like
Bill DeBlasio and Nancy Pelosi were not
taking it seriously and Joe Biden were
not taking it seriously in those early
days
de Blasio didn't lift a finger when he
finally did order the lockdown he
himself wouldn't lock down he got into a
little bit of trouble because he was
still going to his gym and they they
said mayor de Blasio how come you're
telling everyone else they can't go to
gym but you're allowed to go to your gym
and he said well you know I got a
workout I don't I feel I don't feel good
when I'm not working out yeah okay well
Bill de Blasio gets to go do whatever he
wants but the people do not and that's
what this is all about this is if this
were about protecting public health he
wouldn't have gone to his gym but
because it's not because it's just a
power grab you you've now got a policy
that has been implemented in every
tyrannical regime throughout human
history which is
the trouble with tyrannical regimes you
is you can't police everybody all of the
time there just aren't enough government
thugs to police everybody all of the
time so what you need to do is turn the
people into the policemen for each other
and you incentivize them in various ways
you say if you don't report on a crime
you're going to be punished crime you
know some infraction of whatever the
policy is if you don't report on it
you'll be punished and if you do report
on it you'll be reported and it's so
easy a report on it
that is what de Blasio is doing nobody
in New York should follow this policy
everybody should should do their best to
make light of this policy it's
outrageous oh there's also evidence from
one of the world's leading public health
experts that none of these policies are
helping at all we'll get to that in a
second first I got to thank our friends
over at a light stream you know right
now saving every single penny that you
can is particularly important including
on your credit card balance right well I
would don't forget a penny saved is a
penny earned here don't throw your money
away light streams credit card
consolidation loans have rates from just
five point nine five percent APR with
auto pay and there are absolutely no
fees zero zilch nada
say goodbye to credit card bills and
take even more control of your money
listen to what other customers have said
about live stream quote finding out
about allied stream couldn't have come
at a better time I've been trying to
consolidate my debt for a few months now
but I felt like I reached a dead end I
was listening to my podcast one morning
and heard their ad and everything that
was said sounded too good to be true but
at that point I had nothing to lose
ultimately it was true it was so easy
quick and convenient I wish I would have
found out about light streams sooner I
1000% recommended it to everyone now I
hope they were listening to the Michael
Noel's show a person in that ad I assume
they were apply today get a special
interest rate discount and save even
more the only way to get this discount
is to go to light stream comm slash
Knolls that's lig HT s TR EA m comm
slash Noel's canna WL is subject to
credit approval rate includes 0.50% auto
pay discount terms and conditions apply
and offers are subject to change without
notice light stream comm / Knolls for
more information so de Blasio
instituting this policy governor's
mayor's around the country instituting
these awful policies and yet one of the
world's leading public health experts
leading epidemiologists says that the
shut downs are absolutely pointless
professor Johan chisaki one of the
world's top epidemiologist Susan ba
advisor to the Swedish government
he was the first chief scientist of the
European Centre for disease prevention
and control he is an advisor to the
director-general of the World Health
Organization but he probably doesn't
listen to very much he says in three
words shut downs or dumb so this at the
point we are now and what you're
advocating in this be protected groups
better and as far as the rest of the
population is is concerned we just allow
it to pass through the population
essentially essentially yes which is I
mean I know that it's now commonly
understood by what we call the herd
immunity strategy basically because it's
not just the old and frail I mean there
are the people that should be protected
but I don't think you can stop it it's
brilliant
so try you can stop it for some time but
then I mean countries that have been
successful South Korea is giving up now
they can't maintain their policy
Taiwan I don't know about Taiwan they
were quite such as a Singapore similar
problem there's no way you can stop it
listen to what he's saying listen to
what he's not saying because what we
were hearing from people who were
supporting the lockdowns who were both
liberals and conservatives and in the
middle and everything in between
what there's being what they're saying
is either we lock down the whole country
or we throw granny out to die that's not
what he's saying he's saying the old and
the frail and the sick should be
protected the immunocompromised and all
the people who need to be protected
should be protected but
the rest of the people need to go out
and develop what's called herd immunity
this is the policy that Sweden has been
pursuing now Sweden has a higher death
rate than other countries in the region
that's true but the question is not
who's gonna have the highest death rate
for the next two months the question is
now that we know that coronavirus is
going to come back now that we know the
coronavirus is not merely going to
disappear how do you protect the most
people in the long run sure let's say
the United States flattens the curve and
then the curve is like this until June
or July and then the curve goes right
back up again according to all of the
models well ok who cares if the curve
goes up three months from now or today
maybe you're just prolonging the
inevitable if you're prolonging the
inevitable why did we shut down the
economy okay his point this
epidemiologist is that there may be more
deaths up front but in the end the
results will be exactly the same it's
what he says later in the interview so
the only question is do you take away
rights and destroy the economy first for
comment we turn to presidential
candidate Joe Biden i sat with a guy
yesterday on on a telephone and he's
telling me he said I don't always tend
look III walked through the hospital and
he said then I got I got myself in
position where I got the virus so they
quarantine me and and they put me in the
hospital or I made it out and so I'm out
but they don't want me was my family I'm
on the third floor I spent 15 minutes on
the phone I'm saying he said I have a
three-year-old on a four-year-old they
come to the door outside and they're
just not gonna door say daddy daddy can
I see you daddy can I see you daddy
so we spent time going through it I used
to do with my kids there a little and I
couldn't see them and we'd play games I
said not gonna make up a game knocking
knock on the door and say this is you
know practical things the guy scared to
death very insightful mr. president mr.
vice president mr. probably not going to
be future president thank you very much
what is the purpose of the lockdowns I
think people don't understand what the
purpose of the lockdowns is is the
purpose of the lockdowns to stop the
spread of the virus no no one has ever
said that the lockdowns are gonna stop
the spread that cannot happen is the
purpose of the lockdowns to reduce the
spread of the virus no no it's not no
matter how much you flatten the curve
the same exact number of people are
going to be infected
eventually flattening the curve is not
reducing the number of people who get
the virus it's just spreading them out
over time okay so it's not reducing the
spread the only purpose of the lockdowns
is to slow the spread why do we need to
slow the spread so that we can not
overwhelm the healthcare system because
if the healthcare system were not even a
consideration here then you wouldn't
have to reduce the spread who cares
you're either going to get it tomorrow
you're gonna get it today might as well
do it today why procrastinate but the
whole point is not to overwhelm the
healthcare system and guess what we've
succeeded at that ok there are empty
hospital beds in New York they converted
the Javits Center into a makeshift
hospital completely unnecessary they
sent that federal ship down to be a
hospital ship in New York didn't need it
New York was the epicenter in the United
States I suppose it still is and we have
not overwhelmed the healthcare system so
good that's great we'll see whether or
not the reason for that was the
lockdowns sort of beside the point we
now know the only reason the lockdowns
existed we've achieved it so why do we
still have the lockdowns right that's
what that's one argument right there for
ending the lockdowns is they no longer
will serve any purpose there isn't there
is no longer a purpose left that they
could serve but we've got another reason
another reason to possibly lift some of
the lockdowns is there's a lot of
evidence now that the lockdowns might
not have reduced the spread of the virus
much at all where are we getting this
information we're getting it out of
Massachusetts which is now flaring up as
a major center of the virus so
researchers with Massachusetts General
Hospital took to the streets of Chelsea
which is becoming a real hot spot to get
blood tests for people to see if they
had not the corona virus but coronavirus
antibodies that is to check on people to
see if they've already had corona virus
and now have the antibodies because
they've moved past it this has been one
question old time is how many people
have it though all the models are
suggesting that it's a very small number
of people who have it it's just the
confirmed cases a lot of us who were
skeptical have said and I don't know
maybe you've got ten times as many cases
as people actually think if you have way
more cases than obviously the death rate
is much lower the hospitalization rate
is much lower so these guys
Massachusetts general just go out there
and they talk to 200 random Chelsea
residents and they prick their fingers
and they get their blood guess what
percentage of them had antibodies for
coronavirus all of them looked healthy
or you know none of them were showing
symptoms guess what percentage of those
200 people have already had corona virus
and have recovered from it without even
knowing it without going to the hospital
one third almost exactly one third 64
out of 200 have already had the corona
virus they didn't even know they had it
okay now Chelsea is a particularly hot
spot right now for the for the virus so
I'm not saying it's one third of people
throughout the United States but that
means that the number of people have
headers so much larger the flu
comparison might be fairly legitimate
another person who suggests this is Jay
Bhattacharya he's that Stanford
scientist who made huge headlines a few
weeks ago when he went on Peter
Robinson's show and when he wrote a Wall
Street Journal op-ed and he said you
know we think that the actual infection
rate is much higher we think that the
death rate is significantly lower well
what is he doing he's conducted a lot of
research on this far more scientifically
rigorous than just going out and talking
to 200 people and he found recently that
the infection rate when you could when
you're not looking at a hot spot when
you're controlling for different factors
is something like 3 or 4 percent so
obviously not nearly as high as 30 or 35
percent sure but what that means is even
if the infection rate is just three to
four percent then when you compare that
to mortality would bring the mortality
rate down to something like a very
add flou which is what the skeptics have
been saying from the beginning which is
what they have been pilloried for from
the very beginning you know it's a great
thing that Sweden is remaining open
Sweden is not locking down Sweden we're
gonna see what happens when you don't
Institute these national lock downs it
gives us a control case okay we're not
going to know the right answer for many
many months because the death rate is
gonna be higher there for a little bit
but in the long run we're going to see
after the second wave if there's at
least one country that does not shut
down then in two years or however long
it takes to get a vaccine we will be
able to know what that looks like that's
going to be very important to assess our
response here because every single day
all of the new information that's coming
out hour by hour is justifying the
skeptics it's justifying the liberate
America protesters and it is smacking
down the doomsday predictions of
opportunistic politicians the mainstream
media and the self-appointed public
health experts who want to dictate our
lives for us for more on this we turn to
Democratic vice-presidential Democratic
presidential candidate former Vice
President Joe Biden you know there's a
during World War two you know or
Roosevelt came up with a thing that you
know was totally different than a then
the this call he called the you know the
world war two he had the world there the
war production board I think Joe Biden
is rubbing off on me the more Joe Biden
clips I play the less I am able to speak
so that's not great I imagine if that
guy becomes our president there is
obviously we're talking about the
scientific news of coronavirus and
there's a lot of important information
coming out there there's also a lot of
information coming out on the
international front I spoke to Senator
Ted Cruz on our show verdict just a few
days ago senator Cruz broke some news on
that show because he had spoken to the
National Institutes of Health it's all
starting to become a little bit clearer
why a lot
of politicians a lot of people in the
media are trying to cover for Communist
China why they're trying to parrot
Chinese propaganda on how this virus got
started there was a big bombshell in a
report that NIH gave to senator Cruz
we'll get to that in just one second we
will get to Dan Crenshaw committing
absolute murder on the Bill Maher show
is just devastating we'll get to a
Harvard home schooling invective and
we'll get to brian Stelter crying we get
to all of it but first I've got to take
a quick break and say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube head on over to
Daley wire.com you already should do
that by the way you should be members
already why because you get me get the
intro Clavin show the bunch Bureau show
the man well show you get the all-access
stuff if you get up to that tier which
you certainly should you you know you
look you get everything and you get this
the leftist tears tumblr the brian
Stelter smoothie vessel okay you need it
otherwise you're going to drown go to
daily wire calm we'll be right back with
a lot more
so you know obviously I would never say
I told you so but on this show about
three weeks four weeks ago we suggested
maybe hey just maybe there was a link
between the Wuhan Institute of Virology
and the virus found in Wuhan and that
maybe this this story we were hearing
from the Chinese government and the
American mainstream media but I repeat
myself was a little bit of a cover that
maybe this didn't just come from a bad
batch of bad soup but it had something
to do with that level for viral lab that
was just a few hundred yards away
turns out increasingly that seems to be
the case why on earth then was everybody
covering up for China was it just the
money you know China buys up a lot of
American media was it the ideology the
media obviously hey Donald Trump or is
it the case that people knew about this
lab they knew about the research that
was being conducted there and maybe even
just maybe the US government was funding
the research at the lab here's senator
Cruz breaking the news well it turns out
there wasn't just one there were two
labs within miles of where this out
Brook break occurred that we're studying
coronaviruses from bats and and that
there were internal State Department
wires before this pandemic raising
concerns about the security in those
labs and that an accidental a virus
could escape and cause a global pandemic
but I'll tell you it's worse than that
and let me give you some some breaking
news right now which is the US
government was funding the Chinese
research at the Wuhan Institute of
virology your taxpayer dollars and my
taxpayer dollars and let me give you
specifics that we just got today today
an enquiring of the National Institutes
of Health did any of your money go to
the Wuhan Institute of virology the
answer is yes and and and here's what
here's what they told us in writing
today they said in fiscal year 2019 the
funding for the Wuhan Institute for
virology was seventy-six thousand
dollars and this end the 301 dollars
seventy six thousand three hundred
$1 so you and I and every all of All
American taxpayers are spending over
seventy six thousand dollars to fund the
research at this laboratory what
research were we funding specifically we
were paying the Wuhan Institute of
biology to study viral diversity in bat
reservoirs and survey people who live in
high-risk communities for evidence of
bat coronavirus infection and to conduct
lab experiments to analyze newly
discovered viruses so we were paying
them to do all of the research that it
seems increasingly likely was the cause
of the corona virus outbreak that they
then lied about for months and caused a
spread all the way around the world and
shut down the greatest economy ever and
throw 22 million americans out of work
and kill another 40,000 at last count
americans and this is a very bad
situation it also reminds us I think of
two things here one politicians the
media people in government have a lot of
incentives here to cover up what really
happened ton of political incentives ton
of financial incentives okay they have a
lot of incentive to call and anyone who
raises questions wacky crazy conspiracy
theorists right that's what they did
they called Tom cotton the senator a
conspiracy theorist because he said
maybe the virus has something to do with
the laboratory now it turns out he was
almost certainly right and they were
completely wrong that's one thing calls
for a little bit of courage when you're
standing up there
calls for maybe not being so
condescending to the liberate America
people and maybe there's actually good
cause to liberate America that's the
first part second thing we know is that
China lied they lied from the very
beginning and the US media are helping
them do it so here was a report this is
it's so insidious how they do it I was
reading The Associated Press yesterday
for some reason here's the report from
the AP quote the u.s. death toll from
the novel coronavirus rose to more than
40,000 on Sunday the highest in the
world and almost double the number of
deaths in the next-highest country Italy
according to a Reuters tally so
that's not true that nothing listen to
how silly this is the novel coronavirus
they won't call it the Chinese
coronavirus they won't call it the Wuhan
Quran virus it's the it's the novel
coronavirus death toll rose to 40,000
highest in the world it's not the
highest in the world the only way that
the US has the highest death count in
the world from this is if China is
giving honest numbers we know China's
not giving honest numbers you can see
the growth of the virus in every single
country looks like this goes up up up
and then eventually it kind of levels
off here's how it looked in China starts
to go up up up up up then it levels and
then it just completely crashes down
because they stopped reporting the
numbers because they lied by the way you
don't need to believe me on that even
the Chinese government is beginning to
admit some of their lies they say the
death count out of Wuhan was not
accurate they increased it just a few
days ago by more than 50%
and that's still nowhere near enough to
get to an actual honest number so the it
is simply a fact that the u.s. does not
have more coronavirus deaths than any
other country in the world China does
but let's even say that we could move
past that they then right of this
Reuters tally says that the United
States has almost double the number of
deaths in the next-highest country Italy
what they fail to mention is that the
United States is more than 5 times
bigger than Italy population more than 5
times as large so if the US has double
then that's not nearly as bad as Italy
right because you're not interested in
the total number of deaths you're
interested in per capita deaths that's a
much more meaningful statistic so this
is the one silver lining I would say
about the coronavirus it's exposing the
mainstream media obviously you can look
at reports like that and just say this
is so absurd it's it's also taking away
a lot of the mainstream media's power of
persuasion dan Crenshaw US Congressman
former Navy SEAL he showed this the
other night on the Bill Maher show you
know all of the talk shows are still
going on all the late night shows all
the talk shows the news shows they're
still going on but most of them are
being filmed in people's homes so Bill
Maher has his show but he doesn't have
his audience he doesn't have his
applause sign he doesn't have all of the
majesty that goes along with the TV show
so it's just him in front of a camera
and then it's Dan Crenshaw in front of
the camera and without all of those
props to help Bill Maher seem like he's
being the persuasive one Dan Crenshaw
just wrecks him without all of the props
that allow the liberal media to make it
seem like the liberal position is always
correct and the conservative position is
ridiculous the conservative position
shines through just take this one
example of Bill Maher going after
president Trump for coronavirus and Dan
Crenshaw smacking it down
Peter Navarro somebody else who talks to
Trump a lot told him directly January
29th you got to get ahead of this
February later two days later he
implemented a restrictive try a travel
ban from China which he was widely
criticized for I have that same day on
January 31st Nancy Pelosi proposed the
no ban Act which would be congressional
limitation on what President Trump is
actually able to do with that true what
that travel restrictions okay but that's
right man he lies about that he first of
all he didn t lie about it what do you
mean he said he stopped people coming in
from China he did not he said he was
ahead of it 43 countries did it before
we did there are still people coming in
from China he only stopped foreign
national okay let me address that
because I know that's that's the people
are saying right now but the reality is
it was about 40,000 people came in after
that these are US citizens and green
card holders and passport holders being
repatriated US citizens so you have to
make the argument then that that we
shouldn't allow them in and it sounds to
me like you're fully agreeing with
President Trump on this when everybody
else disagreed with them and if you're
saying that you wish that that that
travel restriction had been more extreme
okay fine well you apparently had the
foresight back then but when nobody else
did but the fact is you know if Joe
Biden was in charge at that moment he's
already said he wouldn't have done it he
criticized it as at the time Nancy
Pelosi actually proposed legislation to
stop it but people people are still
coming in from from China it wasn't just
foreign nationals but let's get off that
let me just go back to the
time line for a minute let's get off of
that because uncle uncle stop it Dan
this Earth's too much stop smacking me
down now if they had done that in Bill
Maher's studio he would have had the
audience and the lights and the camera
and they closed up on his face and kind
of smirk or something the audience would
would drown out Crenshaw with his cheers
but because it's just these two people
it's just the arguments and obviously
the conservative argument is much
stronger here I really like this this is
a real as really as a silver lining if
the Left loses all of their
institutional aids to pretending to be
more persuasive to propping up their
weak arguments then we're gonna do a
great job at persuading the American
people this is why President Trump is
holding daily press briefings he's
holding daily press briefings because it
is the Crenshaw Bill Maher moment right
there's it's not NBC News at night with
the lights and the cameras and the
editors and everything designed to make
Trump look bad it's just the reporter
and it's Trump and when you get a fair
fight and it's one-on-one and it's live
Trump wins when it's edited and it's
later at night and they can chop it up
and make it look bad then the media win
same thing here we should we should I
don't think conservatives should ever do
a pre-taped interview again we only live
interviews from now on because we win
every single one of those it's not just
that the media are trying to maintain
their stranglehold on culture the
Academy is doing it too this is the
dumbest article I saw on the Internet
all weekend it came from Harvard
magazine so you know and the title of it
is the risks of home schooling the risks
of home schooling the photo you did see
it's it's got this house and it's a jail
cell and there's some poor little kid
locked behind the the jail cell and
she's looking out so sad at all the kids
playing outside but she's locked in at
home school I guess those kids are in
public school or something and then the
house just has these books and it says
reading writing arithmetic Bible Oh
heaven forfend you read the most
important and wise book ever written
no we've got to read like Sula or
something
you got to read some modern thing that's
so much smarter than the Bible what's
really funny about this though you can't
see it on this photo because I believe
they've updated it the first photo I saw
attached to this article they misspelled
arithmetic I'm not joking
you can look it up it's still on Twitter
if you look so this is reading writing
arithmetic Bible but the original one
that said arithmetic they okay well look
Harvard can't spell the word arithmetic
I bet you every home schooler I know
could spell the word arithmetic and this
is the irony most home schoolers I know
and I know many of them are much better
educated than people who went to public
school or private school or elite
colleges and many home schoolers I know
went to elite colleges they were some of
the smartest kids at the elite colleges
the article begins a rapidly increasing
number of American families are opting
out of sending their children to school
choosing instead to educate them at home
homeschooled kids now account for
roughly 3% to 4% of school-age children
in the United States a number equivalent
to those attending charter schools and
larger than the number currently in
parochial schools yet Elizabeth
Bartholet Wasserstein Public Interest
professor of law and faculty director at
the law schools Child Advocacy Program
sees risks for children and society in
homeschooling and recommends a
presumptive ban on the practice not just
a discouragement of it a ban on
homeschooling you gotta send your kids
to that public school how else are they
going to learn that there are 56 genders
in preschool which is actually being
taught right now in Brooklyn public
schools homeschooling she says not only
violates children's right to a
meaningful education and their right to
be protected from potential child abuse
but may keep them from contributing
positively to a Democratic Society yeah
they're not gonna learn how to go and
and campaign for Bernie Sanders if they
go to home-school
you know they can't be productive this
is the real money line this this
paragraph shows you everything you need
to know about the the article in a paper
published recently in the Arizona law
review she notes that parents choose
homeschooling for an array of reasons
some find local schools lacking or want
to protect their child from bullying now
look that's undeniable
many public schools in different places
are absolutely terrible and don't equip
your child to learn anything at all
barely teach them to read others do it
to give their children the flexibility
to pursue sports or other activities at
a high level that's okay to your kids
getting bullied it's okay if your kid
wants to play baseball that's okay
probably soccer if I'm working with
being honest about these people others
do it for this reason
but surveys of home schoolers show that
a majority of such families by some
estimates up to 90% are driven
dun-dun-dun by conservative Christian
beliefs and seek to remove their
children from mainstream culture Barthel
it notes that some of these parents are
extreme religious ideologue who
questioned science and promote female
subservience in white supremacy they had
to get white supremacy in there because
any time that anybody is slightly to the
right of Barack Obama then you're a
white supremacist neo-nazi right
whatever
now extreme religious ideology very bad
gender ideology and telling
four-year-olds that boys can be girls
and they should chop off their genitals
that's really good that's not extreme
that's not an ideology but saying that
Jesus Christ died for your sins that's
extreme that's crazy nobody can even be
exposed to that because if you're raised
reading the Bible the most important
text ever written the most profound work
that has completely shaped our culture
if you're raised reading that ever like
even once being exposed to that then
you're gonna become a total dunce idiot
and not be able to contribute to society
whereas if you are actually prohibited
from reading the Bible in school then
you can become a really smart person and
not know how to spell arithmetic that's
or then you'll know that boys can can
really be girls and babies aren't really
people and there are 56 genders then you
know in other words you'll be educated
like the people at Harvard I guess
they're oblivious I guess it's not
intentional I guess it's oblivious this
article is very dumb if this is
indicative of
kind of education that you can get it
Harvard no one should go to Harvard okay
Harvard charges $70,000 per year for a
Gender Studies degree and they are now
saying that homeschooling is unfair to
students you know what this is really
about it's about the same thing we've
seen throughout this whole pandemic
control that's what it's about the the
politicians who are arresting pastors
for having church services it's not
about public health it's about control
they're letting the marijuana shop
remain open they're letting prisoners
out of jail
finally criminals out of jail they're
allowing all that stuff to happen
they're allowing abortion clinics to
operate 24/7 but they won't let people
go to drive-through church where they
won't touch anybody that's not about
public health that's about control
mainstream media here they're concerned
not about public health not about what
really happened in China not how these
mitigation strategies are actually
affecting the virus not how we can
prevent a pandemic in the future they
don't care about that they care about
control they want to control the
narrative they want to control their
financial access to the Chinese market
they want to control you and what you
can understand Harvard University does
not care about how children can be
educated the schools are all shut down
the only way that children can currently
be educated is homeschooling they're all
locked at home there's nowhere else to
go and Harvard is actually saying this
should be illegal they're saying it
would be better for your child
not to receive an education then for you
to teach your child something that god
forbid contradicts leftist orthodoxy
which by the way is another term for
idiocy for unreality for ignorant 56
genders that's it that's ignorant
okay arithmatic that's ignorant but
they'd rather your kid be uneducated
then educated in the tradition of our
civilization in the tradition that gave
us William Shakespeare and Dante
and Isaac Newton and like all the
greatest thinkers of all time Thomas
Aquinas right they forget that either
you read postmodern drivel or it's child
abuse that's the control
and these people are cultural elites
self-appointed they're really upset that
they're losing that control brian
Stelter the representative of CNN the
representative of this whole culture he
cried and he didn't cry because he's
afraid of coronavirus and he didn't cry
because he's lost his job he hasn't lost
his job yet he cried because this
pandemic is changing things obviously
some for the worse but maybe it's
exposing some weaknesses of our culture
maybe it's causing some people to start
to lose their control brian Stelter
tweets I crawled in bed and cried for
our pre-pandemic lives tears that had
been waiting a month to escape I wanted
to share because it feels freeing to do
so now is not a time for faux
invincibility sure knows are living this
hating this like everyone else for
comment we turn not to Joe Biden but to
the Godfather Don Vito Corleone you're
gonna act like a man what's the matter
with you what's a matter with you this
is obviously very humiliating for any
man to tweet out ever and he should feel
humiliated but more than that the
mainstream media the Academy the
stewards and gatekeepers of our culture
they should feel afraid they should be
crying because I think they've lost a
lot of credibility in all of this and I
don't think they're gonna get it back
once this is over
I think that we're gonna keep flattening
that curve of their credibility as we
move forward and I think maybe we're
developing a little bit of a herd
immunity to it all right that's our show
on Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Doyle show see you tomorrow the Michael
Noel's show is produced by Ben Davies
and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen